MIKE: It's beautiful
out here, isn't it?
FRANK: Danielle sends us
to a lot of places,
and we're always
on these dirt roads,
these gravel roads and stuff.
Now she's sending us to a town
that only has six people in it.
MIKE: Oh, yeah,
look at this building!
FRANK: Oh, this looks good.
MIKE: Wow, wow, wow.
Dani hit it with this, man.
FRANK: She did.
MIKE: This is so cool.
FRANK: This place
looks good, dude.
MIKE: Oh, man, it's incredible.
Are you kidding me?
FRANK: I know.
MIKE: Hey, you Junior?
FRANK: Junior.
JUNIOR: Yes, sir!
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
Nice to meet you.
JUNIOR: Glad to meet you.
MIKE: Beautiful
country out here.
JUNIOR: Oh, you bet!
MIKE: That's my buddy, Frank.
FRANK: Nice to meet ya.
MIKE: Talked to Dani
on the phone?
JUNIOR: Yeah, sure did.
MIKE: Oh, man, this
place is beautiful.
How long have you had this?
JUNIOR: Oh, for several years.
MIKE: Yeah?
Now, did you run
a business out of here?
JUNIOR: No, I run
a business next door.
MIKE: Oh, okay,
so the feed store next door.
JUNIOR: I went into the business
of farming and running cattle.
JUNIOR: When I bought this,
there was nothing in here,
except two display cases.
MIKE: Okay.
JUNIOR: And I...
FRANK: You packed it in.
JUNIOR: I have went everywhere.
FRANK: Are you still buying?
JUNIOR: Yes, sir.
JUNIOR: I've always
been interested in
history, and preserving it.
FRANK: Never leaves you...
MIKE: Frank, he's got
all the oil cans!
JUNIOR: Penn-Bee is
the best oil can that I have.
FRANK: This one?
JUNIOR: Yes.
FRANK: The Penn-Bee is the best.
JUNIOR: Yep.
FRANK: When it
comes to oil cans,
I thought I'd seen them all.
FRANK: Is this something
you would sell?
JUNIOR: Possible,
but I'd have to think about it.
FRANK: A lot of
places we go to,
the guy pigeonholes himself,
collects one thing.
You know, collects toasters
or collects this or that.
This guy's got everything.
MIKE: What about
the piston rings sign?
Is that something you'd
probably sell, or no?
The Ramco?
JUNIOR: I probably wouldn't.
MIKE: You wouldn't?
JUNIOR: Nope.
FRANK: He's a historian.
He likes to keep
this stuff around.
MIKE: So, is the Dr. Pepper
piece something you'd sell?
JUNIOR: That's a local piece.
MIKE: Oh, it is?
JUNIOR: Come out of
this old building
over here on the corner.
MIKE: What are you
thinking on this?
JUNIOR: I don't think you
got enough money to buy it.
MIKE: [laughs]
JUNIOR: The reason I'm
keeping some of this stuff,
I already have...
several pieces
in our two local museums
that's on loan.
MIKE: Okay.
FRANK: A lot of these items are,
you know, from around this area.
And he's been the preserver
of historic items.
If he wouldn't have kept this
stuff, no one would remember it.
JUNIOR: I enjoyed talking
to Frank and Mike.
Both of them have a real
knack for what they do.
MIKE: When Junior
bought these buildings,
he wanted a place to
run his business out of,
and he also wanted a place
to keep his stuff.
But now he's been there
for so many years,
that he's the local historian.
FRANK: You make...
MIKE: Thanks for preserving
your local history.
I mean that.
FRANK: Darn right.
MIKE: That's a big deal.
FRANK: You got
a lot of neat stuff.
Appreciate it ever so much.
JUNIOR: Okay.
MIKE: Back when he bought them,
he had no idea
that he would basically
be the curator
of them and the town.
JUNIOR: Bye!
[Mike honks horn]
MIKE: Sweet picking, Junior!
♪